[Music]
so how long have you lived here at 28
Barbary Lane I moved here in 1966 and I
suppose it was a different place then
but in some ways not at all someone tell
me I'm hallucinating because I know this
can't be real Mary Ann singleton returns
to Barbary Lane oh my dear it's more
than just an apartment obviously that's
where we go into us that place saved my
life
[Music]
you know it wouldn't be alright to have
some feelings about your estranged mom
showing up out of nowhere
she thinks I am her biological mother
[Music]
and once you feel seen like Anna magical
makes you feel seen you don't want to
leave I don't really know how to
describe it
everything that made me me came from
Barbary Lane Shauna deserves to know the
truth
sometimes the truth is the burden you
have to carry alone
whenever I look at my mom all I see is
that I wasn't enough to keep her here
it's obvious to me that you're the
center of this little universe
[Music]
I call them my children because they are
[Music]
you're way upon
you